er wolle
hallo ihr lieben
künstlich auf heute gibt es unserem
jahresrückblick auf eine art und weise
wie es noch nie gemacht haben die wir
allgemein noch nie etwas gemacht jungs
prima hier
auf unser video auf der action
bringt euch wahrscheinlich so ok haben
sagt doch bestimmt geschnitten und sohn
nein das war sarah unsere kamerafrau und
cutterin die uns seit august unterstützt
die ganze über instagram mitbekommen
oder auch durch die videos natürlich und
sehr dass jetzt wieder auf zwei tage
lang zusammen geschnitten und ein
meisterwerk wie sie sagen haben doch
nicht reingekommen haben wir also ich
habe ganz group rein guckt aber nicht
wirklich einfach nur über geguckt ist
einfach nur schnell was ich beruflich
gespannt wir gucken uns einfach das
komplette letzte jahr an und reagieren
einfach drauflos dreschen reaction die
setzt mir das mal auf nämlich etwas
höhere so
viel sport ausgeht hallo hallo hallo
hallo hallo hallo
sagen
ja ich wollte zum halo auch was sagen
jawohl das ist mir aufgefallen dass
merck mich so ein bisschen sich etwas
anderes machen mach doch mach doch so
eine reaktion
aber das machen wir nicht dass hanna
erstmal okay
du bist du
also ist er entweder praktik gesagt
zusätzlich des videos reden weil der ton
ist das nicht so ganz ja aber so dass
rechnerisch also dafür standen ja gerade
findet also 95 rezeptor doch ein schon
etwas jetzt die verreist und der
50 blog auf unserem blog kanal kann das
kam der rückblick ist schlüssig lux ja
kasse nicht mich auch folge verloren hat
jetzt 50 blogs haben vor einem jahr fast
vor allem in unserem blog kann ein stich
haben war richtig losgelegt ja und sonst
auch einmal die woche da hab ich ja noch
mehr ja
[Musik]
ernähren ist
einfach entsetzlich was passiert den
heizungsraum
und er stand einfach komplett unter
wasser einfach also also man muss schon
sagen das hat wird kriegt schließt
bekommt es ja ich sag jetzt ein wort was
ich noch nie auf dem haupt kein nein
gesagt habe es halt scheiße gestartet
das ja da fühle ich mich so wohl vor
allem kommt das wasser gehört gewalt ist
zwar alles wieder getrocknet du kennst
mich ja nicht nein - ich hab' ich warum
weint ist das ist mir klar geworden dass
unser rückzugsort gewesen wir hatten den
genuss vier wochen
dazu muss ich jetzt auch was sagen wir
hatten ja also wir haben ja in unserer
küche gelebt das heißt wir haben in
unserer küche diese wohn ecke gehabt und
dann immer auch die küche geguckt und
eine oft möglich ist auch nicht immer
ordentlich aus das ist es wird bekommt
nicht immer die krise bekommen haben zum
netflix super ich konnte einfach nicht
schön dann hatten wir unser wohnzimmer
bekommen da wo wir jetzt sitzen und nach
drei was ich danach drei oder vier
wochen ein riesengroßer wasserschaden
und mussten uns komplett alles nochmal
rausreißen und neu machen
eher winterdiesel hast du gesehen
[Musik]
alles gut also zu erklären was passiert
ist wir mussten das alles rausreißen und
dann auch teilweise wegwerfen klar ist
sache des vermieters gewesen aber
natürlich gold hat es immer schon
gegeben und das war echt mies sank er
doch gemeint also einzig dazu sagen wer
mich kennt weiß ich war nie für
materielle dinge ja das ist schon alles
was du sagst du dir vor ich von mir aus
kann ein keine ahnung der mann bringen
ja es sollte also
weggeschmissen werden aus versehen ich
würde gar nicht darum hinterher ich weiß
sowieso alles verlieren willst aber ich
mache also das jahr hat echt wie es
begonnen
aber um das zu verstehen wir haben ja
ein jahr vorher darauf hingefiebert
aber es ist alles so lange gedauert
fieber weiter kein symptom er manchmal
so indem sie eine historische
[Musik]
nein
ich muss sagen
in den ersten nur erst richtig geld tor
gemacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich wollte dass gerade jetzt nichts
sagen weil ich wollte noch warten bis
noch was noch kommt ich würde sich gar
nicht so sie sind flüssig zu halten
reilly tor
und austropop druck ich auch und das ist
geil sondern rezepten das video ist
jetzt zehn monate alt ich bin so doof
dass sie das jetzt 11 monate alt aber es
ist immer noch aktuell das video man
kann immer wieder darauf klicken und das
rezept nachmachen
[Musik]
unscheinbar
unscheinbar aber richtig geil immer wenn
ich zwei poster der ich mir die leute
wach auf diesen so dieser kuchen ist
vereinigt wurden ich hoffe dass du dich
zeit hast diese kuchen noch mal zu
machen ja immer neue machen muss immer
schade
[Musik]
dass
du hast darin auch schon gebüßt ja doch
dachte ich dachte immer an rezepten da
ich weiß dass du da besonders geschützt
ja jetzt hat sich sogar als von san
sebastian getüftelt das soll schon in
die richtung in die ich doch das war
schon ein richtiger hat schon mehrere
fenster braucht aber vor allem ist diese
war die datei
so richtig so
fatal so müssen so als ob du das denn
die masse noch so nehmen kannst ja aber
das krasse braucht man also ich dachte
der tag schon mal gar nix an der theke
geschmeckt hat schmeckt das gar nicht
was die leute bedroht assoziieren aber
das ist eigentlich so erste und richtung
schoko das war schon am sonntag war das
war echt hammer deswegen ist es auch gut
dass du da oben und mich ist es rein
gemacht hast statt ich bin toll ich bin
toll dass analysiert habe die analyse
ist
[Musik]
wieso ist das so windows ist das erste
schiff sich bisher noch das ist nicht
eingetreten also ich muss sagen ich mich
mal ich zocke
gemacht das machen wir das wissen aber
ich muss sagen das war's so ein das war
ein comeback also das haben wir lange ja
bei allen xxl rezepten immer eine sketch
vorher gemacht haben und so
schauspielkünste ausgepackt habe wobei
wir haben ja für einkaufen kann auch ich
habe keine brüder kinderpornos versucht
mir das leid ich also wollte weshalb
kaufen ein bisschen streng gewesen
aber was wir die 100 einfach
kaffee da haben wir auch die kwl ja
stimmt
wären wir auch die füllung sind schon
brotaufstrich meister geworden über das
jahr aber
wir müssen jetzt nicht reden das ist
jetzt wirklich nur ganz normal das ist
nicht normal
wir rufen jetzt im bundesrat ist der
empfehlungen an guten tag und herzlich
willkommen beim kundenservice des
bundesverbands für süßigkeiten
ausreden lassen
verzehrempfehlung
das ist der mito damals den haben über
insta kennenlernte machte lustige videos
wir fahren nach sympathisch wird der
mito super mario das war wie so was der
sänger das vergessen aber dass es immer
mehr auf jeden fall haben wir ihnen über
ein star kennengelernt und sind wir in
kontakt gekommen da durch diese typische
stimme diese werbe stimme der telekom
stimme droge die die bahn stimme hand
stimme und dann so alles grün genau auf
jeden fall jemand kennt sich gar nicht
oder habe ich ihm sofort abgeschrieben
irgendwann mal ist kannst du das und das
und dann hab ich den text geschrieben
was wir sagen sollen wir kommen bei der
bundesverbandes verband für süßigkeiten
verzehrempfehlungen und hass dem text
geschrieben und anstatt das denke ich
bin in bescheuert oder so hat das ist
einfach gemacht also wir können hier
genauso bescheuert ist sie also
wie kann die gar nicht also wir haben
über über ins erkennen gegeben es nie
gesehen bis zum tatzeitpunkt danach
ausgesehen haben wir nie gesehen und das
ist schon krass
diesem orden wir haben sich bescheuert
ein zweifaches stroh reimers
unsere verzehrempfehlung eines kinder
pinguins gestaltet sich wie folgt
knabbern sie behutsam die schokoladen
hülle ab entfernen sie nun die creme
wählen sie dafür wahlweise ihre zunge
oder ihren rechten zeigefinger
[Musik]
aber gut da sage ich was liegen von uns
ich mache jetzt einfach so
gespannt
dieses xxl pinguin hatte lycos da mach
ich denn dann gucke zwischen die zähne
hat so das weiterleben gemacht
dieses gap xxl ein video kann man nicht
viel machen aber mein innerer morgen hat
sich darüber geärgert dass diese
mittlere schoko schichten abgesagt an
der seite vor sich haben als es auf in
style ist wenn man die fotos auf den
start da habe ich das einfach mit so
einer app retuschierten gerade gemacht
fest natürlich etwas war
aber dass er gibt ja schon hammer was
wir suchen sagte der mittlerweile zu
allem wie facebook aber also wenigsten
wissen seine recherchen fotos ist schon
mal nicht also ihr könnt ihr mal gucken
gleich was ich damit meine franz es
nochmal
[Musik]
mein geburtstag
logitech mit die ups mit juves mit jux
von kaufland das war also ich mache
immer die idee nicht alle ideen für den
kauf und kam für mein kind wie wär's mit
einem lotus kate aber nicht mit dem
original sondern einfach mit einem du
ich hab ich bin sprachlos
ist groß
[Musik]
begonnen
haben wir gerne das mikro runter
gefallen spoiler master
ist auch richtig schön
er war richtig lecker
du hast
[Musik]
zwar jetzt alles sehr rezept plastik war
ich muss sagen es war ja auch noch da
und so noch richtig gut kommt draußen
nicht nur rezepte gemacht und jetzt
kommt ein besonderer monat okay ich habe
die meldung bekommen dass das buch da
ist im shop angekommen und ich finds
dahin yahoo
es ist da weil erstes eigenes kochbuch
ist jetzt offiziell da
[Musik]
es war so eine stressige phase das war
mit abstand das stressigste projekt das
ich in den letzten fünf jahren jeder
guckt wir haben doch diese aufgestellt
mit diesem bewegliches läuft ist also
ich bin durchgedreht also wir haben
skizzen ich habe eheprobleme hatten wir
haben uns gestritten weil sie einfach
gestresst waren unter strom wir haben ja
mit dem projekt wir haben es beschlossen
ich glaube dezember ruft wo ich gesagt
habe ich will ein backbuch machen und
ich dann und ich geboren habe ich mit
zusammengerechnet wie lange es dauern
würde und ich schaffe ich niemals
niemals und dann haben sie gesagt ecke
ganz ehrlich du bist doch auch oft gerne
in die orientalische schiene macht doch
ein orientalisches kochbuch und dann
bringen wir das auch passend pharma dann
raus also ich muss auch sagen wenn sie
haben jetzt jetzt nicht wirklich und es
um copiapó rentenmarkt kenne ich auch
gar nicht aus ob es gute weg bücher gibt
aber ich hab gesagt weißt du was du hast
die besten rezepte ist christa eltern
also von der mama du hast es jetzt meine
mutter und mit meinem eigenen touch
christian das weißt du nachher so du
bringst halt einfach diese kulturen
zusammen und und besitzt auch richtig
mal vernünftig und macht das auch
schrittweise cool so 'ne mit richtigen
angaben und nicht macht mal so ein
bisschen salz und bisschen pfeffer nach
gefühl und so also dieses kochbuch wo es
ist kein reines kochbuch ich hab auch
backrezept drin wenn ich daran
zurückdenke
es war das ergebnis war das schönste der
welt dieses auch das feedback das
schönste der welt von euch wie als wärme
baby geboren der weg dahin also nicht
ich habe keine negativen ich glaube wir
haben auch also es gab leute die das
buch zurück geschickt aber das war
vielleicht fördere leute keine ahnung
ich weiß auch gar nicht aus welchen
gründen buch ist einfach so aber ihr
müsst euch vorstellt wird aber auch gar
nicht so ich will nur über diese
negativen sachen sprechen aber bis dahin
ich denke dann auch wie kasse konnte ich
so kaster rezepte hausball an obwohl ich
so fertig war weil ich war in meiner in
diesen küchen rechteck gefangen obwohl
ich meine küche liebe war das wirklich
gut dass sie und das baby gitter oder
dieses wohl besser wenn wir sie nicht
überfordert reporter von das können wir
machen hier hinstellen und ich hatte
auch dieser titel wurde groß dass man
das nicht so ich war die ganze zeit 24 7
und bis vier uhr morgens habe ich dann
immer gekocht und nebenbei getippt und
ich brauche ganz allein und ich habe im
vorfeld dem mann gesucht der mir einfach
sein wo ich sage hey schreibt mal die
und die gramm zahl auf aber ich hab
keinen gefunden oder rheuma mit mir
nebenbei die küche auf zwischen ich
musste man immer wieder auf ruhig hatte
niemand mal niemand also meine freunde
arbeiten also niemand hatte zeit und ich
konnte die man haben muss doch auch
sagen komme wenn man so ein projekt
machen wie das zum beispiel da macht man
das machen wir ja nur das als vollzeit
berufen effekt oder falls ja was
nebenbei aber du hast es ja schon
überhaupt schon so viel zu tun mit dem
rezept videos das war ja nicht normal
ist ja gerade dass jetzt ein bisschen
mehr gemacht wegen doktor weil er
einfach lange weil anja und ihr wolltet
in die rezepte haben und das war auch
noch mal das war schon eine belastung
für uns und das kann man auch und ob und
hatte man sowieso ein elefant um alles
klar wie ein elefant echtzeit trifft es
aber wie gesagt nicht negativ war das
ergebnis das schönste der welt sind also
so viele besucher aus rostigen mit so
vielen positiven werte muss der hang zu
viel herzblut drin und das bei euch
angekommen ihr habt mir das sieht beehrt
mehr also alles was nach vor negativer
habt ihr schon mal drüber reden fertig
fotos geschossen hat ist der feste haben
und die fotos alle geboxt auch noch mal
sehen und [ __ ] wir jetzt steht das für
uns bucht gehört und ist das layout und
mit ihm sieben und zu sagen haben merken
[Musik]
du hast so unglücklich was dieses cloud
technik dann nein sagen
konnte
was ich ganz ehrlich ich erinnere mich
an diese in diesem moment da nicht aber
der tag nicht weiß eigentlich aufs essen
gestreut ist noch an dem tag kam ein
vater kurz vorbei da nicht vergessen ja
stellen ich muss mir sagen ich habe
richtig hunger jetzt in dieser prozess
an sich der macht spaß und ich gehe voll
auf aber
damals nicht am ende und habe ich aus
versehen an die augenbrauen zu dem die
zunft einen tag vorher an sich der macht
spaß und nicht mehr voll auf aber dieser
spielverderber dieser ganzen geschichte
ist einfach das aufbäumen
einfach spielverderber
so lachen nie so billig wie komm wir
machen es gibt aber schlimmeres mein
gott ja das schöne wahre haben sie bald
die ganze zeit bei mir und wenn ich
irgendwann mal so um 2 uhr morgens die
krise die sich mehr und es ist wirklich
also ihr dürft euch das nicht vorstellen
dass ich hier die ganze zeit und die
krise gekriegt aber es war ein
anstrengendes projekt worauf ich jetzt
umso stolzer bin das ist jetzt hier
liegt aber ich würde sagen ja nicht
gemeistert
[Musik]
eine gesegneten ramadan leute
blog also leute die nicht wissen was
ramadan ist aber da ist ein ist
eigentlich der wichtigste monat islam
wir gehen nach dem mondkalender heißt
jedes jahr verschiebt sich hamann datum
10 tage ramadan fastet man von
sonnenaufgang bis zum sonnenuntergang
man darf ich erstmal doch nichts trinken
weil daran strafen und doch gar nix
inter gemacht man darf nur sitzen mehr
spaß man sollte halt auch in dieser zeit
will sich kennen man sollte halt
wirklich auch seine religion ein
bisschen aufrichtet und über nachdenken
genau zum thema ramadan haben wir auch
wieder schöne rezepte rausgehauen wir
haben ja vor fünf jahren als der kanal
geschafft haben wir mit der ramadan
reihe gestartet und seitdem freue ich
mich jedes jahr auf die ramadan reihe
ich will aber auch nicht dass so andere
sachen zuvorgekommen
ja ich will auch nicht dass andere
sachen zu kurz komme ich habe wenn ich
nur muslimische zuschauer seit der
kunterbunt und das ist auch gut so ich
versuche dann auch immer in richtung
weihnachten so ein garten in diesem
thema noch mal rezepte zu machen aber
ihr müsst auch verstehen dass das so ein
bisschen mein baby ist weil ich ja auch
selber oder wie er auch selber fasten
und teilweise sind ein paar rezepte noch
vor gedreht aber den großteil drehen wir
dann während ramadan verschieben die
drehzeiten auch später fotografieren
alles und essen das dann wieder ziemlich
das ist doch noch erreichen das ist ja
auch das fiel mir so hast du hast du
lebst also so fasst es ja auch mit und
du hast das feeling und familie und
sowas und ich bin auch so wie sind eure
aufgewachsen ist wie immer so an haben
wir dann so dann gibt es halt nur noch
abends zu frist noch wissen was gibt es
heute wohl der cristo es ja auch alles
zusammen kommen ja was dieses jahr aber
gar nicht der fall war leider
ganz vergessen also ich hab mal das ist
nichts für mich das alles ist ja schon
viele schon ja aber schon eine letzte
mann
[Musik]
ich muss sagen da ist ein hype ausgelöst
so viele fonds willkommen geschickt
bekommen das war nicht normal ja und was
man auch freunde gesagt haben und ich
auch selbst erlebt habe ihn so asia
merkt wo du diesen viel zeit braucht es
diesen speziellen ja
das war schon heftig richtig geil auch
wo ich hab voll bock drauf jetzt ich hab
hunger bekommt wo ich vor zwölf ist
nicht ein bisschen gucken
[Musik]
das sieht auch hoffnung
also ich bin 23 jahre alte motorrad und
judith ruhig genau da konnten wir dann
die reihe kiki meets fortführen das ging
bis zu dem zeitpunkt nicht wegen corona
unterhaltsamen es dann auf abstand
gemacht und da ist die generation uns
gekommen und hat ihren abend verloren
wie man sehen kann ich hab dir auch nur
über insta gesehen da hatte ich auch
noch einen relativ kleinen account
glaube ich aber ich habe sie auf jeden
fall gesehen auf der startseite ich fand
es interessant dann haben wir uns kurz
ausgetauscht und ist direkt zu uns
gekommen das fand ich auch echt hälfte
haben wir auch tagelang danach noch
darüber gesprochen kassen so wenn wir
jetzt endlich hätten und so wie können
so dankbar sein euro in china ich bin
mit meinem freund richtung radevormwald
gefahren der linkskurve und sind weg
gerutscht bin ich über die straße
gespielt hat und wenn dann so einen
abhang runter und bin dann am ende gegen
den baum geflogen wobei dann der arme
abgerissen ist der arm ist innerlich
abgerissen also die nerven und gefäße
sind abbau äußerlich ist noch dran an
der
helikopter in unity geflogen und zählt
stunden notoperiert
und dann wurde ich zwei tage ins koma
gelegt mir war klar was da passiert ist
und ich ist es auch es ist schlimm aber
ich konnte es erzählen weil ich halt die
ganze zeit dachte okay du hast überlebt
so
da haben wir direkt gesagt in sevilla
gänsehaut und was ist dieser
wasserschaden bitte gegen so ein
schicksalsschlag näher und die ist
trotzdem noch so mega happy durchs leben
hergeht sina und das auch noch mit ihrem
gewandelt die eigentlich noch die
kommende videos ja
[Musik]
ich meine hand dafür stehe weil ich weiß
ich weiß mit der
hundesteuer
das könnte ich da raus
das ist in kalkar natürlich kein aber
mit seinen flitterwochen vor jetzt knapp
drei jahren und dann waren im april da
und es war so karl dann voll gefroren
sind dann früher abgereist sind einfach
dieses jahr wieder dahin für das halt
nachholen ja wenn es nachgeholt also die
wunde den jahre war da und wir wollen
jetzt noch nicht ja und diese woche
urlaub haben einfach gut
ist aber ist der politiker allgemein
immer kann erklären warum
also nicht weil das essen fertig ist
sollte über einfache
aber ich muss das tor machen
brot und das fand ich habe fertig
gemacht was videos so als
darauf gewartet weil wir so jetzt wissen
auch warum handel schale aus kartoffeln
und sogar papier karton außerdem
wirklich kartoffeln gitter gemacht und
das war wie so ein ball war und da drin
war halt nochmal so hähnchen und dann
nochmal etwas gewürzen und käse drauf
was lecker
[Musik]
also
es ist zu sagen auf
so positiv hob sich kreditgeber
kranke
tragisch ich wo das war pop
also diesen g super league dem weg
oldtimer von einem kleinen laden namens
lockt mal und das war auch so krass weil
die hatten nie gestern auch als erstmal
sondern sondern es hat mir so leid weil
wir auch einen kaffee hatten nicht weiß
wie es ist wenn man der mittags sitzt
und auch gäste wartet dann haben wir auf
instagram quelle gemacht mit dem werbung
gemacht bis heute markieren mich die
leute und schreiben genau wenn die
urlaub machen bis heute dass sie sich
dort was kaufen
[Musik]
der us rapper
ich muss sagen die leute sagen immer
hört offen oder zu filmen
entspannt doch mal und sowas aber
irgendwie immer das macht ja auch spaß
dann ist man ja wirklich nur im urlaub
dann ist es ja auch darauf fokussiert
das ist ja nicht so dezent wie du musst
das machen wir erst mal aus spaß aber
das ist sowieso eine andere sache wo
sagt ok entweder mich ständig aufgemacht
wir machen ja auch also kann haben wir
noch hobbymäßig auch filmen und auch
irgendwie musste ich vor gerne in dem
film und tonaufnahmen ich habe zuerst
mal droht ohne benutzt hat viel spaß
geworden ja
[Musik]
stark und wir kommen zur nabe was geht
zum personal sondern bewahren immer mal
operiert weil der zuspruch war immer so
schön wie man kaum nachrichten hey durch
dich habe ich die leidenschaft zum
backen oder zum kochen entwickelt das
für ein tipp würdet ihr gerne den
angehenden youtube geben ich glaube man
sollte niemals aufhören also vor allem
mal geduldig spielen und dann wenn man
aufhört hat man schon verloren und immer
man selbst bleiben sich niemals
vorstellen nur weil man wie viele
rückschläge man hat na das sieht das
dass das sieht man gar nicht mehr wie
oft wenig noch rascher hieße mies
gelaufen und so egal machen trotzdem
weiter wir sind auch manchmal dauern das
wieder mal so friede von der kuh
[Musik]
deswegen habe ich
das ist daun ist dass eine heimliche
signal an die leute dass ich dachte dort
sind und blogs sind
so seht ihr euch bei diesen zehn jahren
bestimmt oder kinder
ist das kann man also ich wusste ja auch
vor ein oder zwei jahren nicht fasst
jetzt ist deswegen verstehe die bitte
aus
ich glaube im urlaub vor
eigentlich hätte liegen müssen
ich weiß jetzt ist deswegen man kann es
gar nicht planen aber wir wollen so
lange wie möglich noch weitermachen
[Musik]
ja
das ist einfach so sommer trotz
sommertourismus immer das war ja
eigentlich aus dem aus türkei ein laden
der als musterfall ist so eine art wie
sie objekte baklava am donnerstag in der
türkei
und der bitte diesen kuchen an und ultra
beliebter da komme ich mache immer noch
japans ist eine konditorei weil wir im
mcdonald's so abwertend für den namen
finde ich jetzt
ja da findest du überall halt ja genau
was kurz der akku ist gerade was
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das kannst du isst man sieht die ganzen
bilder im fernsehen kann man nun so wie
es hat mir wirklich also in wahrheit ist
es nicht
[Musik]
das war eine krasse szene als ob sie
gerade superheld film gerade wäre und
und durch die knall von dem superhelden
mit dem shopping ist sowas passiert am
ende also so richtig so surreal ist das
also die flutkatastrophe gerade weil
diese zunahme war haben wir gedacht okay
wir sind keine journalisten was sollen
was können machen wir haben dann gedacht
wir machen einfach
essenspakete fertig auch vor allem für
die für die helfer dort zum beispiel die
auch richtig mit anpacken wir haben im
bauhaus ein paar sachen gekauft und die
leute waren super dankbar was wir nicht
gemacht haben wir haben keine personen
gefilmt oder so wenn man einfach nur
darauf aufmerksam dass fahren haben
haben auch alle gesagt online geht nicht
hin hälfte nicht im gegenteil als wir da
waren haben wir gesagt wir brauchen
hilfe genau was ihr macht zum beispiel
essen vorbei bringen einfach für
zwischendurch man könne dort nicht nur
zu was nebenan kaufen oder so und das
fand ich krass dass alle gesagt haben
hälfte nicht oder geht nicht dorthin um
einen wahrheit brauchten leute hilfe ja
ich wollte mir auch das manchmal schon
an dem ort zu fünf sitzt also wenig aus
wie möglich das sind jene verkehr ja das
hat ihn allgemein klar dieser fall hörte
ich auf jeden fall also da jede helfende
hand hat er mir geholfen also bei
jedermann ist ja wenn man so eine
familie ist somit zwei kindern mutter
vater und man sich vielleicht auch nicht
freunde hat oder vielleicht die freunde
selbst betroffen sind wer soll ihr
helfen so ist kann dir keiner helfen du
kannst ja nur von außerhalb dafür
bekommst du kannst ja nicht jetzt dein
kind dadurch
eintragen lassen oder so willst ja nicht
sondern das muss ja sehr machen halt im
endeffekt war es ist jetzt ein halbes
jahr her ich schreibe immer noch mit
zwei leuten die betroffen sind und diese
also da doch da ist noch gar nichts die
sind immer noch irgendwo bei anderen
untergekommen bei bekannten aber deren
eigenes heim das konnten noch gar nicht
also ich habe gesagt ja wie sie es denn
und so stellt euch dann bald eine küche
oder so kommen wir gar nicht gar nicht
möglich weil die wende hin zum run ist
[Musik]
rot und gold ja freunde familie alle die
zeiten sind gekommen und ich höre ich
immer so ich habe die zeit im koffer
waren es fast so viele berge
[Musik]
kompletter szenenwechsel das soll man
einem backkurs das war es erst muss man
viele auch gar nicht so mitbekommen über
instagram und über die kaufland
prospekte wurde das quasi als
gewinnspiel verkündet ihr konntet euch
dann teilnehmen über die kaufland seite
ich glaube so etwas hätte ich auch
alleine auf die beine gestellt aber ich
glaube ich hätte ich habe diesen
arschtritt einfach gebraucht das
kaufland sagt so heers mal lust mit uns
ein bacchus irgendwie zu machen aber ich
habe dann quasi inhaltlich alles
organisiert also was für ein rezept das
wird und so weiter das hat für mich
vollständig ja aber es war muss aber
sagen aufgrund der pandemie konnte sie
auch selbst so hat es ja selber angst
dass etwas passiert also du wirst auch
nicht verantworten dass etwas passieren
da hat jetzt kaufen rücken die natürlich
dann alles organisieren beziehungsweise
du das noch mal organisiert hat und aber
es war schön das war wirklich schön es
ist was schön man musste halt die ganze
zeit die masken tragen klar so emotions
mäßig fast ein bisschen eingeschränkt
aber sicherheit geht vor grad so wenn es
unserem bacchus geht nach dem svh aber
es war es war schon krass ja aber ich
muss sagen dass dieser zeitpunkt also
die regel war schon genug hat eigentlich
eine maske tragen
müssen weil er war auch sehr sehr wenige
xander krank aber trotzdem musik machen
system aus sicherheitsvorkehrung
gefallen ist ja auch ein gutes bier
vorgenommen aber es steckt schon viel
arbeit und vorfeld dahinter und bacchus
zögern ist es nicht mal eben so bemerkt
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es wieder
einen
dichten jetzt so in den kopfhörer buchse
ihre stimme ist krass also es war zu
gast bei kimi synchronsprecherin super
bekannte rollen aber einen der aktuell
bekanntestes tokio von horst des geldes
und heftige stimme ein gemeinsamer
heftiges wesen einfach danke man jetzt
mal abgesehen ist von ihrer
synchronsprecher stimmen und so die
selmer crazy crazy diese ja
aber die kann 0 backen die kein
schlechter bank hat sich sogar aber dass
sogar selbst das hat man wieder gesehen
sie wusste ich was nicht
also wer das video in noch nicht gesehen
hatte wusste jung ist angucken es
vielleicht haben wir ja aber das richtig
los
also heute gibt es eine folge kiez mit
der wunderbaren esra also deine okay das
direkt sagen tokio haus des geldes
dollar ist
der kette zwischen leben und tod
ansonsten hast du noch pretty little
liars and high school musical schaffen
die habe ich auch sehr gerne rudi
gesprochen
[Musik]
wir tranken jetzt israel in dem wie sie
nach einer sprachbox versucht
aber das war das wollen wir so wie die
idee die halb so viele rollen schon
gesprochen macht es ja schon selbst ein
kind ist und das team wusste sie gar
nicht mehr oxidiert gesprochen hat oder
nicht ich kann nicht lange bleiben wie
hatte du hast auch koga miyata
sie in kabul
hat die das war das abgesprochen
gemeinsam
die szene fehlt will denn so oft
stadtbilder ja guckt euch das mal anders
es ist echt
[Musik]
lecce
war schon richtig gut wir müssen jetzt
richtig klappen
würde daher raten wir
sagen das ist mir glaubst oder nicht ich
habe heute mittag noch gefächerte
vollbank auf diesen tick tock bürger mit
den tomaten stadtbahn ich weiß warum ich
hatte richtig bock drauf denn ich bin
noch kein bock drauf
das war okay
das noch
[Musik]
weil das ist cool ich mag immer sachen
die man so echt essen kann
der wanderer nicht immer noch lieber
auch gestern morgen zu hause und die
haben sich auch so gefreut die sogar in
kamen ein videowagen können wir ein
video also die haben sich richtig
gefreut die gucken sich das doch ohne
ende
jp morgan wurde und deswegen gehe ich
jetzt eben schnell etwas kaufen ich weiß
nicht was ich habe gar keine andere wahl
betroffen
sind also ein tag volkes geburtstag
haben dann beim einrichten und
geschlafen die hat die video gesehen
haben und sie waren wie dieser kommen
überraschen sie macht zum morgen ist
doch schön
[Musik]
heftig haben wir uns ist der wahre
stärke
das war alles ein tag netto hassan ein
großes super der firma von
ja das war krass erstmal so mag ich
diese überraschung dann beim indoor
gegessen und in
pakistan wobei das ist eher das ist ja
das bewährteste ist und dann noch beim
wollen und nachdem in den bohrkernen ist
der tag vorbei dann vorbei ist viel
gemacht da haben wir im kino ist haben
an dem tag habe ich meine ein
supertolles wird alten dort vergessen
dass meine schuld
[Musik]
was diese was diese diese aufnahmen
diesem verbirgt
[Musik]
medellín
also dazu muss ich sagen das haben wir
zwar september gedreht aber dass wir
konnten ja auch das ist soweit die
gummis folgen die kommission verzögert
online aber stilvoll froh dass das dann
auch noch nehmen konnte werden durch
corona die solar eine lange pause und
werden auch so wieder unterschiedliche
gäste das liebe ich von china zu es auf
einmal synchronsprecherin wann wieder
loni der schminkt und morgen ich finds
richtig war das format ich liebe das
wieder eine chinesin mit einem heute
wirklich albanerin albanischen im promi
make up artist nämlich jetzt einfach mal
es ist lohn
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich habe sein letztes jahr august
tatsächlich vor einem jahr quasi
magenbypass habe dadurch hat sehr viel
abgenommen ich war sehr übergewichtig
das war so beste entscheidung meines
lebens getan aber führt direkt an dass
man ein ganz anderes lebensgefühl und
herren wir benutzen natürlich der gute
weizen und normal der ist auch richtig
entertainment vielen ja und ich muss
sagen ja dann auch als jeder gast
entstandene geschichte und ein snack
abdecken und da hat ja das mit einer
magen op solche teams folgen haben für
mich so ein bisschen podcast er hat sich
noch heute zu kommen
spezielle art von cookies mit einer
wunderschönen beschichtung da brennt
nichts arme und wärme verteilt sich sehr
schnell
und gerichten gut heißt es wieder nicht
gesehen habt event wieder erkennen
barcelona hatte ich so sehr gefällt du
hast eine fremde frau
es hört sich natürlich schnell so wird
auch nicht normal das ganz anders
ich kann mich trifft klare ist diese
operieren
das waren wirklich so in den spiegel
guckt doch zum minister wirklich wer ist
das einzig im falschen körper unterbau
ich mal kurz weg weil sie so kommen die
schminken sich jetzt aber was kurz weg
dann kann ich mir zurück bist du es ist
schon krass also wieso kurz operiert und
dann raus
das war's aber erst sein also sie
partners erkrankten profi der nicht der
grund welt
gutes pinsel müssen und die ganze
restliche video dieses bändchen mit dem
man die augenbrauen hochzieht dir und
auf gutes essen das gleiche bekommen
video aber das band jetzt habe ich zwei
tagen ganze gedacht
zwei mal zwei mal sorry ich weiß wie
teuer ist das ist aber den erst
einmal lachen muss aber so extrem wie
jetzt ich wusste das ist kunden ggk
statoil kocht ich möchte
einfach und man hat mich bekommen hallo
ihr lieben heute einen neuen gast beck
chemie das ist jemand der einfach immer
auf den straßen ist wer fahren welche
mal über ihn es ist
für mich hier zu sein sehen dass du da
bist
du so kommen wir machen wir beide wir
nehmen beide unsere letzten youtube
videos youtube studios und zeigen was
sie verdient haben damit
haben wir das sind sogar noch ein gutes
video da war schon zu gast bei uns und
else h was machen wir falsch was machen
wir falsch also nur von youtube allein
können bin ich leben der shop nicht dann
muss aber so richtig das video
ausgesucht
es geht ja um den umsätzen 28 tage hatte
ja aber ein unterschied dass einmal
unterschiedlich sagte jedes folge ist
ist einfach spannend das ist öffnen
nicht diese stupide rezept zahlen auch
das ist bei uns in die studie aber es
ist nicht dieses reine rezept sondern
das immerhin noch was drin
das ist sogar noch ein gutes video bei
mir
[Musik]
aber es sind ja immer so
rum sagt in kassel sind ist sowie
kurze straße
[Musik]
die cookies fand losgeworden oder besser
gesagt genau das wäre geschafft djk wir
cookies haben wir zusammen zu hause
gebacken und dann gehe da habe ich auch
vorher bei subway gekauft und die leute
für straße kunden entscheiden was die
leckere finden bleibt tasting
man sieht das anders
jetzt wird krass jetzt kommt so richtig
gegen ende des jahre war der höhepunkt
zu neuenstein da haben wir nachts in
einer kleinen filiale unseren werbespot
rita moser was gefehlt hat jetzt am
anfang war natürlich dass wir die haus
getrieben auch gelohnt haben und das war
auch krank da ist warum das nicht mit
drin aber das war nicht noch im dezember
das war so ein paar jahren ja genau aber
amerika anfang januar hat das richtigen
halb gehabt da ist angefangen nicht
normal der shop ist einfach 23
derweil komplett überlastet mitarbeiter
waren waren wir endlich genug war
einfach so so die besteller aufkommen
der wahl startet so aber dann kamen die
hausherren aber das sowieso nur von mehr
als eur gestiegen und das war das auch
zu händeln das war schon krass was dinge
ist immer also ich finde mal so wir
bringen wir bringen schon so viele
lebensmittel auch aus und wir tüfteln
auch mittag und sehr vielen aber es sind
besondere es ist richtig die man so aus
der stange von der stadt gekommen vom
markt bekommen sagt immer so klar gibts
haselnuss kremstal gibt's auch schoko
krebs aber was machen wir dass unsere
besser gehen leckerer wir und da wollen
wir schon 1000 mal 1000 leute es gibt
solche unterschiede es gibt solche
unterschiede und das wird einfach noch
mal gezeigt dass wir dann im oktober mit
in kauf während drinnen waren quasi das
listet waren bei kauftransaktionen aber
es muss man also youtuber als
start-up-unternehmen erst mal schaffen
zwei jahren über den englischen könig
karl seit zweieinhalb jahren wieder über
kann behaupten dass er ein produkt im
einkauf daran halten ja allgemein mag
das sind gleich eine handvoll messetag
ich bin das auch krass und das ist ja
nicht nur das was dass wir uns als
freunde für uns ist es schön dass da zu
sehen aber auch ihr habt ihr dann dieses
dieses feeling diese kurzen wege dahin
eher eure stories so geil einfach diese
dass wir uns so gemeinschaft das war ja
bitte das anders
netflix sein vater
[Musik]
was hast du gemacht
ja herunter legendärer tag gehabt sogar
ein geschäft war nun es großes team
oliven alle so tollen damit habe ich was
hat bei uns im lager
nachfolger im kopf und das ist wirklich
unser lager das ist keine irgendwie
kulisse extra dafür sei aber ich finde
so klasse unten gedreht
hat
[Musik]
also die leute ihr müsst ihr euch
vorstellen tritt der tresor tiere die
waren so schwer ich musste das spiel
also so schön da wird es halt
authentisch rüberkommt und ich finde ich
mir ein guter schauspieler ich finde das
ist ein online also ich könnte der
nächste parlament werden
[Musik]
meine green ab dem 14 oktober in jeder
kaufland filiale
bmw
assist sagen das war also wir haben also
unter der videos auch und da manchmal so
viele also noch nicht mal unsere
zuschauer die geschrieben haben dass
videos krass das war richtig nett sechs
charaktere auch alle meine freunde
familie oder etwas hat die vermutlich
schon gedreht dafür heftig und das war
nur eine nutzen ob wir haben 60 sekunden
nach 40 stunden
und ich ungeschminkt
ich komme gerade nicht klar ich bin am
zittern ich bin richtig an twitter nicht
ich bin richtig stolz auf dich haben
jetzt steht ihr aber nur für kurze zeit
wie gesagt das ist gerade ausgepackt
worden und ja denke es wird nicht lange
stehen
ich denke es wird nicht lange stehen das
war den mittwochabend bevor es dann
wirklich am donnerstag
es war wirklich in nrw gefühlt an einem
tag länger ich weiß dass es diesen
brocken wenn die gott ja genau aber auch
in nrw also 48 stunden da war das
meisterwerk und auch generell ich klicke
instagram nachrichten das war fast
überall mich geärgert was ich auch doof
fand natürlich eine denkt man das ist
okay es ist weg es war ein erfolg aber
andererseits die chance dass sich alle
bekommen habt im markt schöner erfolg
so wenig ein paar merken so das kann man
hat nicht einschätzen
die haben halt jeder hat seine ware
bekommen jeder hat seine displays
bekommen 23 je nachdem aber selbst wenn
dann ein bisschen mehr drin wäre
dagewesen wäre der wahrscheinlich
trotzdem sagt es bekommt weil andere
chance zugegriffen haben also es ist
schon schwierig zu kalkulieren so
welcher marke bekommt dadurch ist eine
aktion auch ist es ist ja noch eine
zweite liste gewesen ja aber man kann
halt nicht punktuell sehr sagen okay der
bekommt mehr druck und werde auf jeden
fall war es halt nur in aktion man kann
herrlich mit dem finger schnipsen und
ist dann irgendwie in einem riesen
supermarkt gelistet so einfach ist das
leider nicht aber wir sind für diese
aktion so dankbar dass das so einen
meilenstein für die gesamte community
wie ich finde es so weiter geht es mit
rezepten im oktober
[Musik]
also ganz andere sache drin genau
so
einfach anderen durch
das ist das eine
daran
denkt einfach du bist eine
küchenmaschine
dadurch dass ein wahrer film kann haben
sie öfter mal richtig vor die kamera ich
unterhalte mich zwar haben sie ist immer
da ist immer da auch so steht der durch
und dann quatschen wir uns so aber
dadurch ist er halt mehr so richtig vor
der kamera und dadurch konnten wir die
10 zusammen machen das auch schönes
video geladen was im camp sicher so
sicher ja man sieht das zwar aber ich
bin aber ich habe das zwar im video da
dachte ich weitermachen aber der schoko
war krank ja das war eigentlich also
kommen die meisten städten schon gut
schmecken lecker ja aber auch nur in die
warmen sind aber ich bin gut aber ich
bin jetzt nicht so sage brauche ich muss
das jetzt hinter essen aber diese show
künftig interesse fand ich auch gekommen
wenn auch nicht drin
heute macht man das nach gerichtet
[Musik]
doch warum graffitis war kann man so
viele dieser geschickt haben ja so hohen
akku
[Musik]
aber da war auch relativ soße hatte sie
ihren zweiten frühling bekommen zwar im
herbst ein frühling wenn man merkt also
man kann es sich für trader benutzen wir
legen heute unbedingt probieren ich bin
echt lecker werbung
[Musik]
seid ihr bereit für die leckersten
schoss schnitten der welt ich liebte es
über alles und ich habe mir gedacht
warum macht dich einfach schnitten braut
ich verstehe bis heute nicht warum die
situation ja das verstehe ich auch nicht
ich habe mein job so youtube gesagt hat
wir wollen nämlich ich habe selten so
viele fotos bekommen ich habe setzen wo
so viele bilder kamen weil dann
sebastian cheesecake das war also nicht
nur mal eine galerie mit screenshots von
überall instagram tik tok ergibt das
vertrauen in touristen sind heftig
heftig einfach gesagt warum wir uns
jetzt zurück weil es schmeckt wie
ziellos durch diesen trick sonntag dass
ich gar nicht weg sondern durch den
kosten heißt es schmeckt des cellos ja
es geht um geschmack genau
[Musik]
koreanische von dort also auch so
herzhaftes food borne war dieses jahr
echt so richtig gesehen ob gesehen
[Musik]
es ist dass sich alle rezepte es ist
immer noch ein paar highlights beim
verein werden auch kfz schicken wo ich
das ja auch richtig geil
[Musik]
18.12 geht's los
die cocos kreta wir stellen ja wo denn
der sachse ist irgendwo
am 10 12 also wenn man sie probiert
beckmann die recht halten raffaello
innere von raffaello wirklich mit diesem
hauch von mandl aroma noch arbeite jetzt
nicht gedacht dass es noch mal durch die
decke geht wie die hazel cream und es
hat mich sogar kokos dass wir so ein
spezieller schmalz wurden anzahl in dem
kurzen zeitraum mehr heise also in
kokons besteht als hesse ich
interessiere und deswegen auch limited
edition weil ich wusste es nicht mehr
sagen kommen wir hatten bedenken die es
ankommt du hast indirekt nachdem du
diese bis zum nächsten tag mehr als die
hälfte auf 5 60 prozent von bestandes
weg gerufen nachgestellt aber ich gehe
es geht ja darum coco so hasselhoff muss
creme allgemein ist ja so dass gibt
jeder chor ist ihr okay ich gesagt ich
mag ein kokon ich mag ein baugleicher
verschicken das mittig der grund warum
wir damit sie sich jetzt haben so weil
wir nicht wissen wie gut es bei euch
ankommt ja ich muss auch sagen ich habe
eigentlich immer so ich weiß auf jeden
fall das klappt aber diesmal technische
sicherheit wissen wir haben mit limited
edition gemacht weißt du was das problem
ist also das problem ist online online
kann man es nicht auf die schnelle mal
probieren aber sobald man die probiert
ist es so krass ich lecke gerade die
kugel eines raffael uns aus und das habe
ich bei anderen kokos ich bin ehrlich zu
euch was ich am aufstrichen probiert
habe man guckt immer wie schmeckt kann
ich andere aufstriche steht das kein
vergleich eine gucken haben vergleichen
auch wir wollen auch wir wollen was
leckeres bekommen so und dann gucken und
dann haben wir gemerkt wie sich diese
schiene kokos ist gar nicht ausgeschafft
es schmeckt gar nicht richtig über
hauben
vielleicht wirklich ohne spaß also ich
bin nicht schlecht reden aber mache ich
habe ist doch egal aber es hat wirklich
nicht geschmeckt
also hätten wir jetzt die rezeptur sorge
macht ist wird das so unzufrieden das
schmeckt aber genauso wie keine ahnung
die von rewe oder so jetzt mal haben als
beispiele da hätte kein anreiz ist raus
zu bringen aber dadurch dass es wichtig
ist innere das also macht doch keinen
spaß das ist ja das geistliche scream
wenn das christkind kommt da knallt
knallts aber sofort voll da nur sagen
aber es ist wirklich so also wir reden
jetzt nicht umsonst und weißt was ich
einfach nur krass für mich diesmal
musste ich meinen kopf die leute
gestellt online kokos creme nicht nur
eigentlich bestehe 6 oder 10 23 da hat
sich das ist auf fünf jahren gedacht
dass überhaupt jemand das war ja wieder
geschrieben das nenne ich blindes
vertrauen du lounge eine queen und ich
kaufe 6 steht und das ist wirklich bin
dass vertrag also habe ich meine
bestellungen gesehen und dann gucke ich
so das packst du da einen unterschied so
was denn der 120 stück bestellt so ich
komme den tisch lieferscheine diese hält
was geht ab und gucken so die nächsten
kisten weil wir aus dem kassensystem 10
15 10 6 10 20 uhr was geht hier ab alter
das ist schon krass ist das also ich
finde es einfach dieses vertrauen ist
einfach krass und nur durch dieses wir
liefern abliefern geile rezeptur ab
wirklich man sagen ihr vertraut uns und
und dadurch ist es so dieses dadurch
können wir weitermachen und noch mehr
krems entwicklung scheint großes markt
bleiben so weit gespannte combo ja
hallo wenn ihr euch wohl etwas da haben
sie auch mitten im video macht wir haben
euch was sehr sehr schönes zu verkünden
wir haben nachwuchs bekommen in der
kirche screen family und rokoko skating
screen kokos limited edition aber mal
schauen wenn er sie auch gefeiert
vielleicht jetzt da kein element endlich
sagt mal ganz ehrlich wenn du sagst du
magst keinen kokos du wirst es trotzdem
leben ist echt so
ist soll
[Musik]
das ist einfach mein christ schub
bekommen aber einmal bist du leute
langsam gestartet ja ganz viele auf wo
vollmer und ich weiß nicht verhält es
sich überhaupt noch auf ist in
zusammenarbeit mit kaufland entstanden
aber ich sage ja diese partnerschaft das
ist einfach so ein mehrwert mein gott
ganz ehrlich ob der jetzt und mensch ist
im glas oder in der pakt müsse es sein
so verkauft ich liebe diesen mehrwert
wenn wir mal kooperation haben und mit
kaufen ist keine kooperationen seine
partnerschaft aber selbst wenn du was
ist denn was
marx ich glaube es ist ich glaube das
spricht auch für youtube user aus der
seele werbevideos wenn der bewerber wie
du da steht das wird nicht gut geklebt
ja das ist so ein bisschen gedrosselt
habe ich es wirklich so stimmen sie dann
checke ich nicht ist aber so schade
eigentlich aber man muss sagen bei uns
wären die werbevideos kommen da sind es
jetzt an sich keine werbungen und sie
drehen sich etwas an oder so was dran
das ist halt immer so schön wie sehen
sie das das hat die milch im kaffee ist
wie gesagt dass im glas nimmt oder ob
das neue paket gehören ja
[Musik]
sehr
stark ich geb ich muss dazu sagen dass
ist das ist leider ein sehr schlechte
kippes video was du ich hab mir heute
einmal rüber gehen like it konzerne
werben das schlimme ist das ist
eigentlich gar nicht so dieses aber es
ist so zahlen basiert und wenn ihr auf
youtube analytics geht und sollte
youtuber guckst du diese analytics immer
dann steht einfach bei diesem video rang
eins ist das beste und das schlechteste
10 von 10 und das ist einfach das macht
mit 219 verletzte acht von sich tagen
genau wie dies genau von letzten videos
hat es am schlechtesten abgeschnitten
und ich schwöre es euch ich muss
aufpassen denn es macht manchmal was in
meiner psyche dass ich mich so richtig
daran aufhängen aber so zart und das
kann man noch immer machen warum kriegt
das keinerlei vorsorge stehe es war also
du sagst immer scheiß drauf
manche sind manche manche rezepte dass
wir noch am falschen tagen gepostet
nicht jetzt war das weil wir es falsch
war sondern mal kommt sonne und dann
guckt keiner meldet schiff das ist so ja
jetzt weihnachten dann hast du jetzt so
alles gerade beschäftigen alle da
draußen wer weiß auch eine lok dann
kommt die woche war alles geschenke und
das ist auch der grund gewesen das video
gesehen ansonsten immer unsere
unterhaltung und auch wenn die kamera
aus ich
versuchen
doch zahlen
[Musik]
also lust hat kann einpacken
damals war
sarah ich hatte man auf sponsoren keine
ahnung ich habe die absicht sagen danke
einfach nur ein großes danke für diese
extrem geil ja mit euch ja es gab höhen
und tiefen hat man jetzt auch gesehen
aber es gab erhöhte aber es gab wirklich
mehr erhöhen und nächstes jahr was also
wenn ihr wisst was euch dieses jahr
erwartet ob man gut ihr würdet also ich
also nicht immer so mensch lasst mich
erst einmal in trockenen tüchern legen
es ist ja schon fast anton entwicklung 1
prozent
ich habe es das verrate ich dann ist es
was war da ich habe es jetzt was
verraten das
einladen können aber es ist bleibt
stellen obwohl ich als bürgermeister ich
denke so ende monat ungefähr gibt ein
video anrufe das erzählen oder
circa einem monat gehen wieder online
es ist so werdet euch so freudig schwöre
sollte aber ich komme mir sicher dass
jeder aber es wäre sich viele freunde
dort doch glauben ja ja ich weiß dass du
mein also ich muss sagen ich richtig
herzklopfen wenn die sache ich habe
panik ich habe angst aber ich freue mich
auf die herausforderung ich werde euch
leute kiki ist sie ist der einzige
mensch der der immer ein bisschen
negative filmchen in dem projekt
mach dir keine sorgen aber das ist bei
voll viele sachen ja das ist verfolgen
ich denke zu realistischen denkt zu sehr
an was ist wenn das schiefgeht anstich
gehen du kannst deine community oder ja
ich kenne die community also aber diese
sache ist echt sofort die macht mir
angst naja du kannst diesen krankenhaus
gekommen habe sich das ziel gesetzt das
los mit dir auf
jeden fall heute ich danke euch wirklich
wieso nachfolge ja ich freue mich aufs
nächste jahr wenn dir etwas auf dem
herzen habt dann schreibt es gebe jetzt
in die kommentare werden alle kommentare
durchlesen und mit euch schreiben sie
was wirklich wirklich ja ich bin also
dort wo noch ich mal 70 prozent wo ich
dadurch aber sie das ist jener ist
momentan ja und ich antworte auch den
meisten neu bzw ich kann nicht einen
antworten aber glaubt mir ich bin so oft
es geht vom morgens wenn ich aufstehe
direkt kommentare kommen fahrbahn fertig
oder instagram direktnachrichten man
wollte ich auch jeden tag mindestens
eine stunde manchmal 203
gucken ja gleich mit man kann mit dem
gerät erst einmal gucken wir film gucken
war dies immer irgendwie mach ich bin
echt stolz
selbst als es bei microsoft von der
woche in unwichtigen stellen warum
also leute danke euch wie das
wundervolle jahr 2021 heraus zu
verzeichnen und dass sie hat 2002
2022 scheiße also macht euch keine
sorgen kroner mit nächster flachen das
wird krank dass wir zu krank danke für
direct of direction ja auf jeden fall
spaß mache ich hoffe euch dass wir die
auch spaß gemacht und wir sehen uns in
alter frische nächstes jahr zum guten
rutsch ins neue jahr
hat sich ruth schmid ist mit rutschen
minute
einbruch